cris j'aime bien que tu t'es pas vu tout
mais
c'est glee qu'est ce que t'es fait que
ce que tu as vu david goudreault merci
de nous accueillir dans votre atelier
d'écriture pour parler de jack kerouac
est-ce que vous souvenez de la première
fois que vous avez lu sur la route et
jusqu'à quel point ça vous a marqué et
influencé
sur la route c'est un roman date de
naissance je pense qu'il faut lire à
l'adolescence parce que il ya une espèce
de mouvement mais j'ai l'impression que
ce côté le voyage le trip la
consommation à les amis l'amour ça
raisonne par l'adolescence donc je pense
qu'on livre que j'ai lu au bon moment et
des jeux qui me donnait envie d'écrire
c'est peut-être aussi jack kerouac en
psy et brel qui disait le talent celle
envie de quelque chose je pressens que
kerouac il avait une envie de dire une
envie de se découvrir à travers
l'écriture c'est quelqu'un qui sait
beaucoup cherché kerouac se cherchait à
travers l'écriture ne trouve à la
consommation à travers la religion à
travers la spiritualité incarné dans ses
relations
et à l'adolescence on se cherche
beaucoup puis après on sapin et zou peau
mais pour moi sur la route c'est un
romain qui reste jeune et qui résonne
pour les jeunes dans votre famille on ne
parlait pas anglais voilà lancés dans la
cabane la maison c'est ingrat
franco-américain parce que c'était le
francophone anglophone en table d'une
amérique qui cherchent à les peuples
sont des aspects qui me touche qui
m'émeut avec jack kerouac c'est son lien
à notre langue ces mêmes sont liés au
territoire en les kerouac bord du fleuve
il ya fait un voyage assez particulier
un moment particulier de servi aussi
pour revenir au québec mais ce qui est
clair c'est que non seulement il était
un francophone d'un un sens descendant
direct de québécois il ya une partie de
sa culture québécoise et son côté
francophone sont même transformés en
francophilie il aimait le français et
vous voulez écrire en français dans un
français très particulier mais qui
l'habitait profondément il soit dans
leurs autres suppôts l'histoire de
l'histoire ex football
il évoque il donne à la machine c'était
la corroborer il y à cette fameuse
entrevue avec fernand séguin au sel de
la semaine avec jack kerouac qu'est ce
qu'elle vous dit cette entrevue le sur
le personnage parce qu'une chose entre
l'ire du jack kerouac et le voir et
l'entendre parler en français mais aussi
il ya une différence mais pour moi il
n'est pas si grande parce que kerouac ce
d'abord un grand sens m dans tous les
sens du terme c'est quelqu'un qui avait
une sensibilité sur l'époque ce propos
et xavier ça vient lui la beat
generation la beat generation c'est oui
le rythme mais c'est d'abord milité tout
d'abord est battu l'humain donc
il la sensibilité des gens matures et
qui la vie a été dur qui peinent à s'en
sortir qui pensent parfois des
difficultés à un autre on évidemment
l'alcoolisme évidemment ces tensions au
niveau relationnel son rapport à la
littérature soit par au monde et terrain
donc c'est pas quelqu'un pour qui la vie
a été simple et ça paraît
je veux parler du recueil la vie et
dommages sont tous les textes en
français de jack clairoix absolument
extraordinaire 13 ans arrive là il faut
lire sa folie ça c'est tellement une
belle porte d'entrée pour découvrir le
lac et wac pour ceux qui se disent
bambins s'entassent à noter que la peine
que je m'y mette la vieille dame en jeu
travail colossal que fait jean
christophe cloutier en alain non
seulement découvrir commenté
parfois même traduit je pense qu'il veut
un travail de lecture travail de moine
derrière et là on voit que jack kerouac
écrivait beaucoup en français avec ce
phrasé particulier qui est le sien on a
des notes même sur sur la route en
dehors de ça a été aussi sur la route
dans ce roman était passé en français et
donc débarrassé de tous ses appareils
retour à la langue maternelle qu'il a
parlé jusqu'à l'âge de 6 ans et parlait
seulement français jusqu'à 6 ans le web
et là il arrivé et nous et nous dit
qu'il est vraiment qu'est-ce qui vous
qui vous attire à l'ol plutôt que
camilla ou à san francisco je connais la
police
il ya ce passage extradé dans la
bouleversant windy 1
quelqu'un quand je me fâche chaque
souvent français quand je rangerai
souvent en français et quand je braille
je braille toujours en français donc
cette sensibilité le qui est sienne la
racine profonde qui retourne à l'enfance
toujours les écrivains on s'en sort pour
s'y relaient la mine inépuisable de
l'enfance on le voit dans ce passage le
de la nuit ma famille que je pense en
1954 jack kerouac as atteint vous pensez
qu'on va le lire encore longtemps david
dur ou encore des centaines et des
centaines d'années tant qu'ils délivrent
vol l'impasse que jack kerouac il est
intemporel peut-être même immortel d'un
point de vue littéraire et c'est cette
construction l'eau qui est unique keira
kerouac unis qui permet non seulement
vous américaine se l'approprier sont
fiers des kirouac les américains dont
québec on devrait être fier aussi
d'ailleurs moi je comprends pas qu'il
ait pas de statut dans le bas du fleuve
si l'anglais
lors de la vo pour de vrai s'émerveiller
voir le fleuve appareils t quelques
kilomètres plus loin la cellule le
fleuve et digérer une immense d'être se
croit quand même c ses origines
sont là on espère que cet appel sera
entendu merci
j'en appelle à la poésie et à la
sculpture de kerouac
j'ai prêché points 9 le courage
et même chose que je fais c'est une
histoire
[Musique]